[Music]
zander parish has been the principal
dancer at the marienski and saint
petersburg since 2017. a yorkshireman
from hull in the top role at one of
russia's most famous ballet companies
my plan was to come here for a year
try and learn some russian style get
some experience try some solos maybe see
how far i could come just by being in
the center of classical russian ballet
which is what this place is basically
the miniski theatre is the mecca of
classical ballet
parish has been dancing since he was
eight years old he trained with the
royal ballet school and then spent four
years at covent garden but felt that he
wasn't getting the break there he wanted
i was consigned to the spearholding
roles the working on holding various
coats or trays or cups so i got very
frustrated
and out of the blue
my fairy godfather i have to say
appeared
a valley master from russia came to
common garden and taught class one day
[Music]
i saw in a class
a beautiful young man who's just
probably first second season in the
company
and he's so pay attention for my
correction
and he's working so hard
but
he was so weak
very weak like a dancer able to be like
my tutor in act one oh wonderful not
anymore not after 12 years with the
marienski and a total immersion into
russian life and culture it must have
been very challenging though you came
here you didn't know anything about
russia you didn't know anything about
the history you didn't know anything
about the people you didn't know the
language that's correct it was very hard
i must say it was
it was a leap of faith
he's relaxed backstage a confidence
which comes from having mastered your
art but it's also his style friendly
helpful and extremely self-effacing
so does a little bit of nerves help
before a performance there's certainly a
natural adrenaline that kicks in when
the show is getting about to begin
and you've worked hard for performance
you've prepared you've done what we can
do then it's just that moment of waiting
for the curtain to go out
[Music]
and this is literally minutes before it
does
the marienski's director of ballet yuri
fettev who brought parish over from
london stays on stage right till the end
the little swans practicing their famous
dance in trainers and christmas socks
as the audience take their seats on the
other side
[Music]
the male dancer's primary role is to
make the ballerina look good and to make
her comfortable so if i can achieve my
my goal to make her comfy and to keep
her on her leg keep her happy then you
know you're halfway home it's going to
be a good show
i've sacrificed a lot to be where i am
uh i didn't have a social life for
20 years whatever like i've literally
worked my my socks off to to get to
where i am and i
i don't claim to be the best dancer
around there are many other dancers who
are much more talented than i am i was
quite what's the word i was very
tenacious i wouldn't give up and i
really wanted to succeed
a british prince in a very russian fairy
tale parish has also been awarded an obe
for furthering relations between the uk
and russia a symbol of friendship
between people at a tense time between
their governments
dynamagnay sky news st petersburg